where did we come from how did we go
from an expanded universe with the hot
and cold spots in it to here we are
having our little planet that's a nice
place to live how did that happen and we
also really want to know are we alone
everybody wants to know that my personal
opinion is no we're not alone but the
neighbors are really far away even
though we know most stars have planets
we have not found any systems that
resemble our own solar system yet
there's a lot of mystery here Dr John
Mather senior project scientist of the
James web space telescope which has been
in the news for some reason uh we don't
know I mean maybe it's because uh John
uh his his chapter in in this book which
he doesn't even have a copy of into the
impossible uh this I'm going to send you
right after this interview John forgive
me uh John how are you feeling how are
you doing right now I'm great and I'm
greatly relieved because uh now that
we've gotten to this point uh I'm just
beginning to think of all the things
that were dangerous along the
way yes everything that could have gone
wrong didn't didn't go or could have
gone wrong didn't go wrong but it still
must have been incredibly ner yeah well
I wasn't nervous but maybe I should have
been other people were because they were
actually taking care of all those things
that I should have worried about and so
funny of people were nervous doing their
job so anyway yeah so appreciated and so
thrilled that it worked perfectly it is
so perfect it's beyond expectation it's
it's almost Beyond hopes so uh that it's
Optical quality is brilliant so we
promis defraction limited quality images
at two microns wavelength and it's
almost twice as good as that and John
just from a human perspective I believe
you started working on this in
1995 uh I did Kobe was still going on
back then how did you how did this work
for you what was this career step like
for you how did you have the courage to
do this and and what does it mean after
almost 30 years oh my goodness well Kobe
was just finishing we launched the Kobe
in 19 1989 and we ran it for four years
so I was more or less finished with my
part uh by 1995 and I'm thinking what to
do next and I was surprised I got a
phone call from NASA headquarters would
you like to work on this new Mission
we're starting a study and I thought
absolutely this is the coolest thing
I've ever heard of I want to work on
this and I still think it's the coolest
thing and that's saying a lot cuz Kobe
uh changed changed my life because it
happened right when I was starting
graduate school back at
yeah yeah it certainly did and it
changed your life too eventually you
would uh win a Nobel Prize with with
George Smoot uh for that work did you
have I know like those of us that have
children are blessed to have children
those of us that are blessed to have
more than one child we always say when
they're when they ask us I used to ask
my mom you know we have there four of us
four of us Brothers said mom who's your
favorite kid she said that's like asking
me to choose my favorite arm and I'd say
Mom you're right you're left-handed
you're left-handed mom come on but all
the stuff that that web can do do you
have a favorite well I just I think
taking pretty pictures is my emotional
favorite so what's the science behind
that well the first objects that grew
out of the Big Bang material that's the
continuation of my fascination with the
history of the universe something's out
there that we didn't expect I think so
so just recently we're just getting a a
hint from theoretical predictions about
how the first gigantic black holes might
have grown it's one of those top iies of
science we we uh detected the Dark
Matter effects we detected the effects
of dark energy and we still do not know
what made the giant black holes grow we
know little ones can grow from stars
that blow up uh but we can't really
figure out how the big ones got there
and since there's a big one in the
middle of every Galaxy that's a disaster
for un comprehension we got to deal with
this though we got predictions of course
but now we have to get pictures and data
and so that's one of our top challenges
yeah yeah indeed so I was able to take
uh take some questions for my audience
it's over 100,000 people that are part
of this project that I call into the
impossible it's your second time on the
podcast and I'm so uh so grateful that
you took this time during this week we
only have about 20 minutes uh before
your next series of meetings uh but um
but I wanted to maybe start off with uh
just a personal question uh not a
personal a question for me um when we
look at the results and the impact
they're having on society as a whole to
what do you attribute this Fascination
is it the pretty picture phenomenon or
is it really the the the public has
gotten accustomed to these fantastic not
only images but the data from things
like Hubble and things like uh all the
other great NASA projects and
groundbased projects too what um what do
you tribute the the fascination of the
public this is so Arcane and and it took
so long why is the public so interested
in this I think they're interested in
the same question I'm interested in
where did we come from what's the
history how did we go from an expanded
universe with the hot and cold spots in
it that we measured with the Kobe to
here we are having our little planet
that's a nice place to live how did that
happen and there's so many steps that
astronomers can work on uh the formation
of the stars and the galaxies and the
black holes and all that stuff how do
the planets grow uh and U of course we
want to know and we also really want to
know are we alone everybody wants to
know that uh my personal opinion is no
we're not alone but the neighbors are
really far awake in other words a good a
good planet is hard to find and even
though we know most stars have planets
and quite a few uh we have not found any
systems that resemble our own solar
system yet which is to say three or four
little rocky planets in the middle then
four or so big uh cold gas giants way
out there uh we don't have anything like
that to point at in what we've found so
far so what's going on our solar system
might be special so we know Earth is
already special here in the solar system
it's the only place where we can live
and um so what's going on how come
there's a lot of mystery here and of
course we all want to know is there life
on Mars and we can find out by going
there and getting some pieces and
bringing them back how about other
places in the solar system that are may
be possible like Europa where there's an
ocean under the ice or how about on
Titan where there's uh lakes and rivers
of methane and Ean um stuff could be
happening that we could find by actually
bringing pieces home and that would be
even maybe even more exciting than our
beautiful
pictures yeah exactly and actually that
THB Tails nicely with uh with the first
question that I received from one of my
listeners and just a reminder on my
YouTube channel Dr Brian keing you can
submit questions for almost all my
guests I always give a preview of who's
coming up next and I had on uh not maybe
not so near neighbor to you uh as well
nearer than those aliens that you talked
about John uh and that was Bill Phillips
of uh nist in in gathersburg he was on
recently I solicited questions his
episode's coming soon but first question
does involve planets uh and it's from
April van Ryan and she asks my main
question is does web have the potential
to see a small rocky planet close to us
and what is Mei likely to see when she's
used to her maximum potential I have a
billion questions but those are the
first so I guess it's about it's about
Miri and about the small rocky planets
the WASP 96b which you did release
spectrum of this week your team is a gas
giant uh not unlike Jupiter as I
understand it but can you see a small
rocky planet like the distance from the
Earth to the sun we can see them
indirectly we see them when they go in
front of their star it's called
transiting
uh and well here in the solar system we
watched Venus do a Transit across the
Sun a little while back and the sun
detect got extremely tiny bit fered for
a little while because some Starlight
sunlight was blocked we do the same
thing with uh little planets way out
there we will several dozen planets in
the first year including about two dozen
little ones U but unfortunately for us
the only ones we can study are the ones
that orbit very small Stars uh mstars
they're called and so the planets are
very in very close and it's a pretty
hostile place for a planet so we'll
study them some people think they will
surely have atmospheres other people
think surely they will not so we will be
trying that experiment as soon as
possible like I'm not sure when the
first ones come up in the scheduled it's
pretty soon right so we'll try that so
the other thing she was asking was about
the Miri which is the mid infrared
instrument and we will be using it for
this Transit spectroscopy study also it
is neither none of our instruments are
capable of seeing a little Earth
orbiting a a sunlight star it's just too
th but um we do have pretty good
performance for our chronographs which
enable us to see brighter planets
orbiting Their Stars so we are going to
be trying that we're obviously going to
try the obvious cases what about Alpha
centor what about Proxima centor we will
look uh plenty of people think we won't
see anything but of course we have to
look yes that's right it's uh the Wayne
Gretzky principle you miss all the shots
you don't take uh so AB but there's how
many and and the resolution's so
phenomenal my thumbs rather occupied
right now holding up good old Carl Sean
but yours is free to push that like
button and don't forget to subscribe it
really helps us with the algorithm now
back to the episode uh but I want to go
a little bit further out one of my uh
listeners or viewers rather Jimmy Jazzy
asked the question can web rule out or
comment on the uniformity of the
universe exactly he's referring to the
cosmological principle there's been some
um some claims recently by groups uh in
Europe and other where uh other places
that you can actually um potentially
have questions about how much the the
CNB dipole and the distribution of
quazars and other galaxies align with
that or don't um what about going to
cosmology in a survey sense is web
equipped or positioned in any way to
look at things and and see potentially
to comment on whether or not the
cosmological principle might have some
some need of an update we of course did
not set out with that as a major
objective uh we just said we will study
everything you can see with an infrared
telescope because it's all new we got
the pioneering observations with the
Spitzer telescope um if you want to
answer questions about is every place in
the sky basically the same you need to
study a lot of sky so the next big
telescope throwing up for that purpose
will be uclid from Europe and then the
next one after that is Ours from NASA
it's called Nancy Grace Roman based
telescope it's a 2.4 meter diameter same
as Hub but takes a 100 times as much sky
at one bite so it will be really good at
surveying to look for those cosmological
questions is every place really the same
or is there some funny business going on
um about the expansion so too soon to
answer your question but yes uh so
another listener uh is asking a viewer
HC traveler is asking um Can when will
the Trappist one system or will the
trapist one system be viewed by web I
think we're starting right away because
it's an obvious candidate I do not
remember for sure when the first
observations will be you know we cannot
see every Target all year but I think
I've heard that this one's coming up
soon so uh how does the prioritization
work again you know thinking back to
children and you know we scientists are
are kind of like children you know we
we're curious we're imaginative but you
know we don't play well with others we
don't like to share our toys with how do
you prioritize you I mean among all
these phenomenal science goals that you
have equipment to look at how do you
prioritize today we're going to look at
this tomorrow we're gonna look at that
okay well of course we do it with
committees so that's the natural thing
for astronomers will will you you have
to send us a proposal ran if you want to
observe something with a telescope you
have to write it down send us in for uh
uh this discussion and you have to prove
that this is a good idea and that you
know what to do with the data when we
give it to you and by the way you are
supposed to tell us everything about the
concept but you're not supposed to tell
us who you are we want to review this
with not without knowing whether you're
I don't know we we just want to be fair
as much as possible so one curious
result of that is that about 10% of the
proposals we chose were submitted by
graduate students so this is really
great for young people to get in uh we
welcome that and it's a it's a lovely
surprise that so many young people have
succeeded by by writing the best
proposals and of course now if you
choose which organizations are going to
get the picture then you say now what
time of year are we going to observe it
and so that's governed by a calendar
when are they in the line of sight when
can the telescope point at that Target
how long will a web last in an
optimistic uh scenario how many years we
we um are expecting least 20 uh we were
ex requiring 10 uh or even five we but
we got a really good launch basically
perfect launch from the Aran 5 and so we
didn't have to use any extra fuel for
compensating for its errors and now it
turns out we're not even using up fuel
as fast as we thought we would so maybe
even more than 20 years is possible so
if you've just been born you might still
have a chance to use this
telescope that's right so some of our
graduate students graduate students uh
hopefully will be working on this our
grand students WD asked a question uh
thanks you for your great service giving
us eyes that we've never had before my
question is now that jwst is a reality
are there any projects on the horizon
that not only will self assemble the way
that uh the the web did but maybe you
self-replicate could you see a telescope
Factory in L2 uh the way that that uh
that web is but making other uh other
telescopes for the future is that even a
conceivable possibility well people like
to speculate about that and and they we
draw sketches of how we would do it but
so far it looks kind of fanciful because
we haven't gotten to the first steps
everything we've done in space required
astronauts to put it together so web is
uh sort of the most elaborate uh self-
assembling thing we've done for
astronomy and it was pretty scary
because you know when you put it
together you say what if it doesn't work
oh my gosh what do we do then and that
is so well when we started it was
impossible now it is possible to get get
a rocket out there with help so we do
design our next missions with this in
mind possibility of sending help either
robotic or human but at least web was
done without that possibility and that's
pretty scary yep yes you you took the
advice you went into the impossible you
did The Impossible Missy car is a good
friend she's saying this is so great
thank you you're the coolest thing the
question is now about in our solar
system what can it do uh with regards to
say Europa can we look at Europa and
where's most of the exop Planet science
going to come from with web is it images
or Spectrum oh okay well first Europa we
will be watching Europa because it's got
an ocean with ice over it and there are
cracks in the ice where water comes
spitting out and we discovered that with
cble we will be looking at those same
places with the web just see can we see
it with infrared signals and I don't
know just we will try it why would we
care well you learn something with web
but we're also planning to send a
mission out there uh to fly through
those plumes of water and see do they
have other molecules in them like
organic molecules and I don't know
whether they do or not but personally my
guess is that ocean could be alive why
not and in that case look for
complicated
molecules uh so we'll do that so the
other question was more about what are
we going to observe about exoplanets and
so we'll be working on the easy ones and
the hard ones the easy ones are the big
ones like the one we already showed um
where it's a big planet uh and uh obser
obscures quite a lot of the Starlight
and we already know that it's got water
in it uh but when we say water we really
mean steing we will be looking at a wide
variety of these things some hot and
some cold some big and some small
because um we just do not really know
where to look uh we should look at
everything um don't just look where it's
easy look where it's hard um don't
assume you know the answer of what what
the right place to look is as you know
everything about planets was a big
surprise uh when mayor and Kos looked at
their uh data to see if there was a
planet there they didn't expect it other
people had taken data and they hadn't
even looked at the data to see if there
was a planet in there because of course
who wants one of those we want Earth
well there wasn't any Earth in that
system but there were these other
remarkable surprises and everything's
been a surprise so I don't know what the
next big surprise will be maybe it'll be
all those little rocky planets have
atmospheres maybe it'll be that none of
them do and um too bad um no that's you
can't do chemistry on nothing so go
build the next telescope that's what
that'll tell
us yeah there are questions about that
too maybe uh just just when we look out
at the you know current data it's just
astonishing to think that you started
working on this project in '95 and
that's when the first exoplanets were
really you know coming to the light of
reality and and so that wasn't as I
remember that wasn't really part of the
original Mission design I mean of of web
but it kind of has become this this
almost unique Niche that web can can
accomplish I I wonder John can you talk
a little bit about the partnership
between experimentalists like like you
um and and and and observers but also a
theorist a question is coming in about
about that is there what kind of
tight-knit you know partnership I
remember on Kobe from an Outsiders
perspective you benefited tremendously
from the involvement of theorists um how
does that work with web how how how do
is is this an opportunity for
theoretical contributions or is it um
basically they're going to look at the
data and like everybody else how does
that work okay well it's um sort of a
lot of different phases of a project
when uh an instrumenter like me says
well I've got an idea oh that's cool
that's just an idea well why would you
want to do that then you have to say if
you could do it what would you find what
might you find what are the Mysteries
that that would really address so uh for
that we need imagination we need the
people who have already done the work of
observing and they say well I can't see
far enough or the people who do the
calculations see I imagine that this
could be but how can you tell so we
can't get the resources to build that
equipment unless you tell us to so
that's at the beginning then after we do
get along the ways then suddenly
theorists say I better predict what
they're going to see before they see it
so I can get my credit for my proper
kind of imagination and that happened
with the Kobe satellite when we started
there was no per prediction anybody
could believe uh by the time we launched
there were some really good predictions
and some people got it right what we
would see uh other people were
completely amazed they thought oh that
can't be right so um when uh when we
published the map of the anisotropy with
the hot and cold spots there were a few
people that had a a pre-written
scientific paper that was only waiting
for the information to come from our
data release and in a day they had it
submitted so we expect some of that for
the web as well we know we told people
what data we would take uh and what and
they will be ready to plug it into their
papers and say here we are we know what
that means so John I know you only have
about five minutes left I want to be so
respectful of your time uh we have so
many questions people are just so
delighted that you're taking your time
and you're you've always been a public
servant in such a wonderful way both as
an inspiration to Young scientists like
when I was young I'm not young anymore
but but my current students but also to
the public you do such incredible
Outreach I want to commend you for that
because not all scientists do that I
always make fun of scci I say you have a
moral obligation to be uh to do Outreach
to my fellow colleagues I want to do
kind of Rapid Fire just because there's
so many questions that are coming in
Andy oats who's a very good friend of
the show he asks is there a chance that
the first definitive detection of an
Exel Moon could come from jwst I would
love it but I don't expect it okay um I
don't know how you do it I know C
retical predictions have been made but I
don't see think anyone predicts that we
could be able to do it this is really
really hard yeah and it may some claim
it's important to the establishment of
life that we have the moon to block uh
you know asteroid impacts and so forth
so who knows uh it may keep the
neighbors even farther away from us uh
Gunner mcabby which is kind of scary
name he asks are there models of what
look like smack what what the smack
cluster would look like uh in previous
uh previous years versus today is there
any way to to do a differential between
these very distant galaxies and see how
many more galaxies are the UN is the
universe producing more galaxies that we
could see from the web data that you
have okay well I don't know that that
specific place but we do have movies
that are made by supercomputers you say
I know how the universe started I've got
the hot and cold spots I know gravity
works this way start the computer
running and simulate everything and you
can get beautiful movies of how the
galaxies grow and U and we have gotten
pretty far with that project um not only
can you make movies about how the Galaxy
stuff would grow but you can even now
make simulated web telescope images
since the web telescope image is not a
movie it's a sort of snapshot of pieces
of the universe at all different times
from now all the way back as far as you
can go into the distant past so uh
superposition of movies of different
places all seen in one picture so we can
do that now and uh someday somebody will
be able to answer this question well but
not
today uh so question coming in again
from olly Wright who's a good friend uh
this Bears more on uh on the guest who's
chapter one in this book uh and that is
our good friend Adam ree uh so you'll
get your copy I'm going to send this out
immediately your chapter your chapter
eight but uh but Adam is very interested
in the Hubble tension so Ali's asking
are there are there observations plan
that will weigh in on the so-called hule
tension from web absolutely it's a top
prayer and AD of course has proposal in
I'm not sure when it's scheduled uh it's
a hard project um because what you have
to do is survey the universe even more
accurately than we've done before so web
has the capability in principle to do
this uh but it requires so many steps uh
this is a a curious situation where we
use the brightness of objects to
determine how far away they are but now
you have to establish that you know how
bright they really are and so this is a
pretty tricky problem so any Adam's
working on it so is competitors yes
exactly we will see what they get and
the way things usually go is we do not
resolve the tension we just get more and
more sure that we're right and the other
person is wrong uh but eventually we'll
find out so in the last minute that you
have uh John there's a question do you
have advice to people in the field uh
just starting out maybe young graduate
students um or even undergraduates do
you have any career your advice we
talked about that in the last interview
I'll put a link to John's previous
interview and of course to the book uh
as well uh but do you have advice to
young people just starting out an
astronomy I would say that our field is
changing rapidly uh as new technology
comes online and so um you can't really
say I know what I'm going to work on uh
in 10 years because it probably hasn't
been invented yet try to get in on the
latest wave of things and you may catch
that wave and like I've said uh graduate
student can proposed successfully to
observe with the web telescope so don't
assume you can do it just because you're
young just give it a try see what
happens yes my m in life give it a try
and see what happens yes and uh so John
I want to thank you I know it's uh it's
10: a.m. out there you've got another uh
important meeting hopefully we'll come
back maybe in a few months when we have
more phenomenal data from the James web
telescope for now I want to thank you
this is uh John ma who's been a Titanic
figure in cosmology see me there's John
here's a picture
uh Johnny will be getting this book Sign
copy along with some from yours truly
and there will be many other
investigators to tell you stories about
what is found with the web uh many other
people that know more about their topic
than I can can ever know so it will be
fun for you too thank you thank you
Brian it's been such a pleasure bye
everybody tune in next time